[Music]
thank you for coming
bright and early alright so here is the
title of the slide that I sent out to
the program so today I promised I would
talk about deploying interactive machine
learning applications with clipper which
is a big project in the rise lab but as
I was preparing my talk in thinking
about what you would most like or what I
could talk about the relates data
science and data engineering in a really
compelling way I decided to change the
focus of the talk and talk a bit more
about the machine learning lifecycle as
a whole and then connect that back to
the challenges in prediction serving all
right so that's my plan for today that's
a lot so before I go into the details of
the talk I want to briefly describe a
little bit about me so I am the
co-director of the UC Berkeley rise lab
which is a new group to devote it to
studying the design of real-time
intelligent secure and explainable
systems it's a group that connects
machine learning research with research
and system design
database data management and security so
it's a really cool interdisciplinary
project and so I'm going to talk about
research going on in that lab today I'm
going to talk about how we're thinking
about the machine learning lifecycle so
I also co-founded turi
this is actually originally called graph
lab and then dot o and then turi never
let me name something I changed names
all the time so turi was a project as a
company that developed technologies for
data scientists technologies that
allowed them to compute more efficiently
to apply more advanced machine learning
algorithms in this single processor to
distributed processor setting compute
out of core these are innovations that
made it easier to do the early model
development process which I'll talk
about more today I'm also a member of
the Apache spark pmc I developed key
parts of Apache spark including the
graphics component of Apache spark which
is languishing there's some more
opportunities to improve graph
processing and spark all right so that's
a bit about me
my research is in artificial
intelligence I do work in data science
have been developing the dentist
science curriculum at Berkeley I also
done work in distributed database
systems and graph processing systems
that's my background all right I'm also
affiliated with a bunch of different
groups so the rise lab I'm also part of
the Berkeley AI research group which is
a new group of faculty a very large
group of faculty studying AI I work on
autonomous vehicles with the deep drive
project as I said I'm also part of
Apache spark and and turi alright so as
an academic I get to make a conjecture
so I'm going to make a conjecture today
that machine learning models are the
next big data and here's my evidence for
that conjecture first everyone is
talking about models and very few people
have them which is sort of how big data
was maybe eight years ago there's a lot
of excitement some people had it some
people didn't but it was had the
opportunity to shape things right and so
big data does and as models do in the
future had the opportunity to transform
industries and so when we think about
machine learning and what its
implications are on industries it's
potentially very big a neat thing is it
machine learning in the small
development is really a consequence of
big data so as we've made progress in
data engineering we've enabled progress
in model design which will in a sense be
the next wave of things we see from our
data at scale and then finally and this
is kind of the opportunity is it today
the ability to get the full value out of
these models requires advanced skills
and expertise specialized systems and so
as data engineers improving this space
could really have a big impact in our
ability to use models in a wide range of
contexts all right so some corollaries
of that is it data engineers of the
future are going to have to become model
engineers - you're going to think about
models is a new kind of data that we
need to manage throughout an entire
lifecycle and we're going to need new
tools to manage this machine learning
lifecycle and so there's a research
group we started to ask what does this
machine learning lifecycle look like
what are its components and where are
there opportunities to improve that
space from a data management to a model
management perspective all right so what
I would was planning to do is spend the
first maybe 15 minutes or so talking
about the machine learning lifecycle as
we have envisioned it in different
components and some of the opportunities
and some of the limitations of the
technologies we have today
so the machine learning lifecycle often
begins if model development if you ask a
machine learning researcher this is sort
of the whole thing right so we developed
the model that's the cool part
everything else after that's kind of
boring model development is where we
take data and build models after we've
done that and I'll make a big argument
for this we then actually should have a
second stage in which we train models we
really consume pipelines and produce
model the actual models that we then use
in a prediction context provide value to
create services to make better reports
and so on so these are three key stages
of the machine learning lifecycle and we
want to think about the challenges of
each of these stages what's kind of neat
is they actually bring different groups
of people together so you have the data
scientists deep in the the weeds of
model development the of data engineer
is helping with the training process and
the deployment of these models will
actually see even in the model
development data engineering plays a
critical role
all right so model development this is
the focus of most of machine learning
this is what we in a sense teach in the
data science class this lifecycle so
I've broken to four kind of stages I'm
going to focus on the top two in the
bottom two and talk about some of the
things that happen in those stages so
the top two are where we go from
essentially getting data collecting it
transforming and visualizing it all
right so here we have to identify
potential sources of data so
understanding the data we have is
actually a big challenge as a data
scientist what data can I have access to
we have to join data from multiple
sources so we're going to start using
some perhaps relational tools to bring
data together and we have to identify
keys or ways of connecting different
types of data we want to address the
missing values outliers a standard
process of data cleaning I'll come back
to that in a moment and then typically
in this process there's a big component
of visualization this is where the data
scientist is trying to build insight
about the data that they're trying to
manipulate so one of the neat things
here and this is an opportunity for the
data engineer the data scientists to
work together is that this does bridge
understanding modeling with
understanding the tools and the
technologies needed to manipulate and
get to that data and so this is a great
opportunity for the data engineer to
provide one of their strong skills to
help bringing data together from
different sources
I will add so we teach in the data
science class a lot of exciting things
around model development the reality is
that model development is kind of boring
so a big part of developing models is
really getting preparing and cleaning
the data either expert in data science
once said that 80% of model development
is data cleaning this preparation
process the 20 remaining 20% is
complaining about that first 80% so this
is a reality today and in some sense
this is an opportunity for improvement
making it easier to discover to
manipulate and clean data for data
science processes something that we
could really improve upon and there are
opportunities to actually use modeling
techniques to work directly on cleaning
day on dirty data and try to learn from
that and maybe learn from the sources of
dirt in that data as well alright so
opportunities to improve data cleaning
but we've known this for some time once
we're done that process we get to the
perhaps more exciting part which is the
actual model development we get to think
about models design algorithms so in
this process we're going to be building
informative feature functions so using
our knowledge to capture how to
interpret the data for a model this is
getting in some places replaced by deep
learning we are designing new model
architectures this is the fun part again
so I get to think of how my neural net
should look or how I'm going to combine
my decision trees with linear models we
often do a fair amount of tuning
training algorithms and again there's an
emerging space of tools to manage that
tuning process and then we often need to
do validation and this is a part where
that's going to get increasingly
trickier right so what does it mean to
validate a model is it accurate enough
is it fast enough will it be accurate
tomorrow how do we check these things in
a more principled way and I'll talk a
bit about some of the research we're
doing to address that all right so this
is in a sense where the data scientist
is most happy and this is a big part of
the tooling and technologies we
developed right so if you look at what's
being built today to help in the whole
data science machine learning lifecycle
all the energy is here right now helping
the data sign has build that first model
collect manipulate
transform data and so on so what is the
consequence of model development what
should we get out of it all right so
when we think of model development the
first thing we typically get out and
this is maybe what a lot of the
technologies including things developed
at turi focused on is simple reports
visualizations dashboards that let us
understand the data so the consequence
is insight not necessarily a solution to
a problem but understanding about the
data or the domain or trying to to
leverage now increasingly there's
excitement that we will take these
models and use them to build new
services right so we'd like to imagine
the outcome of model development is a
model and at this point when I talk with
my colleagues in databases they go wait
a second what's the model so I wanted to
actually be a little bit more precise
about what I mean when I say a model
here so I'm interpreting or describing a
model a function from some input to some
output some prediction and a model
consists of two things it consists of
parameters and these parameters can be
data they are data they can be tens of
bytes they can be tens to hundreds of
gigabytes depending on the kinds of
models that we're using and so just
managing the parameters of the model
actually is in some cases a challenging
problem and then how we use those
parameters it's turned by the structure
this could be something as simple as a
JSON file describing the structure of a
neural net or it could be a large
collection of code that interprets those
parameters and then executes them to
make predictions right so a model is
this kind of weird thing that blends
data code and structure in order to make
a decision
all right so we'd say the other outcome
of model development is a model but I
want to make a case that that's a bad
idea you should not be making models in
the process of model development
counterintuitive let me explain why so
why is it a bad idea to try to directly
produce a model a trained model during
the process of all development all right
so with just a trained model what can we
do well one things we cannot do is
retrain that model right so you have a
model a data science as it worked to
produce this really amazing model
they've given it to you you can't go
back and say I want to retrain that with
new data and I've actually gone to
companies they're like yeah we have this
really good model like that's awesome
huffing you updated look we can't update
it why not because we don't have the
code to make the model again and that
was some complex process it was
developed over a long period of time
using different kinds of technologies so
usually don't want to be shipping models
we want to be shipping something else
alright so we want to go to retrain we
don't gotta track the code and the data
when things break what was used to make
that model how do i D bug it right so
again shipping a model from law
developing process makes it difficult to
debug we need to capture dependencies to
deploy a model as I said earlier it
combines data with structure and often
code I need to know what code was used
during the evaluation or training that
model so I can then use that code and
it's supporting libraries when I go to
serve it and then finally we need to
audit these models it's increasingly the
case you're going to make predictions if
someone comes back owes you know what
that prediction isn't appropriate how
did you come to that prediction describe
your modeling process and these
companies have said you know what we've
got this really good model that our
engineers built a few years ago they're
going to be in trouble because they
don't know how that model came to be the
data that was used in that model right
so it might have to say look you can't
have this user influencing that model
how do you remove a user from a model
that's already been trained all right so
the my argument that is that you should
not be producing models as a consequence
of model development but instead you
should be reducing training pipelines so
a training pipeline is a way of
describing the process of going from
collections of data to trained models so
this is code right and in fact maybe a
way to think about is analogy and
software engineering training pipelines
are like code right so if we think of a
model it's much closer to something like
a binary and you do not want your
developers finishing the development
process and shipping you a binary you
want them to produce code and you want
tools continuous integration tools to
check that code and produce the actual
binaries the models that you would then
use in a production context
all right so training pipelines I think
that and when we studied this at
Berkeley that's one of things we've
pushed towards and if you look at some
of the earlier project like Keystone we
start to specify ways of not just
building a model but the entire
construction the process of building the
model that we can then reuse in other
settings that we can check in and rerun
in a production context
all right so training pipelines can then
be consumed in the process of training
so we've broken the process of training
made it distinct from the process of
model development all right so now in
the process of training we can use a new
set of tools and the neat thing here is
now it's a data engineer managing these
pipelines the build process for models
we can train the models at scale on live
data the pipelines can be reused we can
retrain on new data as it arrives we can
automatically validate the models and
check their prediction accuracy so we
might as we retrain introduce additional
tests and as we'll see in a moment one
of the things we might want to do in the
design of pipelines has introduced a
mechanism to impose constraints in that
model in the resulting models a way of
unit testing we went to manage model
versioning and when I look at a lot of
the startups building tools for model
development this is actually a big step
forward just saying hey this is version
5 of that model knowing its lineage in
the data that was used to make that
version can be very useful for debugging
things when version 5 breaks and the
neat thing is it when we frame it this
way training actually requires minimal
expertise in the models training is
really about taking these pipelines and
instantiating them at scale
and it provides a nice division of
skills so we can have experts in
managing these big data systems these
big compute resources focusing on what
they're good at and then model
development is focused on the design of
the pipelines that they are then going
to execute so training technologies are
also an area where see a lot of
development a lot of the tools that we
look at for for workflow management are
becoming big part of how we deal with
training I have graduate students and
colleagues are saying look we need to
start using air flow in our machine
learning research that's kind of cool so
using new workflow tools to manage the
training process but there are some
limitations those tools and I'll get to
that in a moment
we're also using new scalable frameworks
and actually these are kind of neat
because a lot of these are systems
researchers or systems engineers
building really high-performance tools
for machine learning in many ways
transforming even that early model
development process by having very
scalable systems to do learning alright
so I said there are a few open problems
so I want to talk about some of the open
problems in this space maybe the biggest
problem is context so as we build these
systems that span different technologies
for machine learning for data management
as we use different teams to try to
develop and to train models we often
lose context I want to talk about what
what context we need to capture so we
can better deploy manage debug these
kinds of models and another neat trend
is we had this emergence of composition
it is no longer the case that a model is
a anatomic thing that lives on its own
we are starting to compose the models
that other teams build to improve our
models and that actually has a unique
opportunity to leverage work just as we
do have software to be more efficient
about machine learning but it has a big
challenge or big drawback that we'll
need to address
all right so contact what we need to
track is the how the what and the who so
how is how was the model or data created
when you know the relationship between
the data creation process and the model
we often want to know what is the latest
or best versions of datas and data and
models and it goes without saying we
also need to track the code involved in
each of these steps and we also need to
know who is responsible so being able to
track across people remember these
techniques are no longer isolated to a
single data scientist but now span
multiple teams and sometimes there is
expertise it is hard to capture in the
code the data in the model that you need
to capture by knowing the people at
least involved in those processes so the
introduction of pipelines of focusing
not on the creation of models but the
specification of their creation process
does help address some of these things
but there are still some limitations
right so we need to track these
relationships across different things
you track it across code
what we've started to see is a lot of
machine learning students data science
students even students in my classes
starting to use get to track their model
development process and in some cases to
track their model and their data as well
which has its problems so we do honey
field a track model and data we want to
track multiple versions of that but
using a system like get to track our
gigabytes of files and checking them
into our course website is a terrible
idea is not an efficient way to manage a
system so we need better ways to
associate versions of data versions and
models with versions of code and then
people this often gets overlooked but as
I said earlier we need ways to track who
is responsible for this particular data
set or who is responsible for the
features used in this model and that
becomes more important as we start to
deal with things in composition and
things break one of the challenges of
machine learning is I can't write down a
really clean API specification for this
model I've just produced or unit tests
that can really really carefully check
that and so when someone else consumes
that and things go wrong people are
involved it's necessary to actually
communicate across people to solve these
problems so tracking those relationships
in a sense being able to blame is a
critical need all right so it's context
composition so again an exciting pattern
is that people are starting to put
models together to solve bigger problems
so suppose I wanted to build a cuteness
classifier I might want to do that to
maybe show the cutest pictures on the
front of my website let's imagine that
this is an ostensibly cute dog and I
have a classifier for cuteness I might
be able actually build a better
classifier for cuteness if I could take
someone else's classifier for puppies
and someone else's classifier for balls
so I put those in as features that model
is likely to actually be a really good
model an improved model for cuteness and
so I could go to my database of models a
tensorflow hub if you will and find the
models that I'm that might be used for
this application and add those as
features to my model alright so this is
actually an empowering way to think of
model development it is what we do in
software engineering it is time we do it
with models as well but there's a
problem right so here comes a cat
let's all agree that this is also a cute
cat with a ball alright so we've fed it
to the puppy detector and for whatever
reason the puppy detector said yes that
is a puppy that's wrong but actually
might have been helpful and when we
trained our cuteness detector and it
realized that you know what this puppy
detector gets cats wrong it might say
well if it's a puppy that's a really
good signal I don't need to know if it's
a cat so in a sense models are really
good at exploiting bugs and our other
models right so when we make a model of
feature the the new model the cuteness
detector can leverage the bugs in the
earlier models to improve its own
accuracy now we have a brilliant data
scientist that comes along you know what
that puppy detector is broken they're
going to fix the puppy detector and now
the puppy detector is correct says no
this is not a puppy all right but that's
a problem because the cuteness detector
was assuming that the puppeteer Tector
would get down or wrong it was
leveraging that signal so now the
cuteness detector is worse so an
improvement in one artifact in our
system actually made other artifacts a
system worse and this is hard to deal
with so how do we diagnose these
problems all right
so a big opportunity but we need ways to
track the the problems that composition
creates so we want to be able to track
composition we need to be able to
validate end-to-end accuracy so that
first data scientist came in and said
you know what I can fix this model and
then then they fix it it'd be nice to
actually say hey you fix that model but
you broke all these other models in the
process of doing that right now there
are simple solutions if we actually can
manage this training process in a more
CI like structure
then perhaps we can retrain all the
models downstream so they can compensate
for the improvements in the upstream
models but even then it's possible that
you're a puppy detector was really
useful signal and the fact that was
getting it wrong was important so at
least being able to find the people
responsible for those upstream models or
downstream models can be critical and
then we need ways of doing unit testing
and integration testing this connects to
the the challenge of doing end-to-end
testing but it would be nice to actually
able to test these individual components
leverage things like the cuteness
detector might have assumed that most of
things that C's are puppies because most
things are puppies or cats all of a
sudden when you start getting the puppy
detection correct and it sees far fewer
puppies that might be a signal a warning
that you have a bug or a change in the
input distribution
all right so we'd like to detect things
like covariant shift alright so this
opens up great research opportunities
and that's something we like to study in
their eyes and their eyes lab how can we
improve this machine learning lifecycle
how can we bring ideas and data
management to these problems and so I
want to mention two projects the first
is ground ground is an open day open
source context management service the
goal of ground is to span multiple
systems you kind of think of it as
something like a hive catalog but for
everything so we want to attract the
people to data the code across different
technologies in an open way and so what
ground does is actually introduces a
fairly open data model of built around a
graph that can associate versions of
versions of artifacts along with the
people and the changes that happen to
those versions as a consequence systems
like hive or spark or pandas or
scikit-learn can publish and subscribe
to this service so we made it extensible
so you could build different
technologies on top of it and one of
those technologies we've been exploring
is a system we call a floor which goes
nicely with ground so the floor system
is an experiment management system we've
been developing at Berkeley now there's
actually a lot of excitement today
around the design of experiment
management technologies and a lot of
those again connect to how we manage the
data and the code what we've been doing
the floor is trying to help with false
discovery so we want to actually track
everything including when you look at
stuff so the design of floors is set to
track your entire Python workflow all
the intermediate artifacts and associate
those data artifacts with versions of
the code and the actions you take on
them right and as a consequence we can
do things like flag that you've looked
at thousands of plots of all the
features and you should not be surprised
you found something interesting so help
with the the problems of false discovery
and so what's nice about both these
projects is they actually do in many
ways span
data systems data science and even
statistics so both these are open source
projects ground is a bit more mature and
in fact it's being co-developed with
several industrial groups floor is a
brand new project that hopefully it will
have big changes in the next few months
as the team of graduate students are
continues to build it all right so
that's model development and training
and now I get to the whole point of this
talk which is difference and so this is
a remaining step in this process of the
machine learning lifecycle I mean in
some ways this is the one that's least
developed in part because very few
people make it all the way through this
part of the process so we have
increasingly fewer models that all move
all the way to production and go beyond
dashboards and become parts of services
so here the goal is to make predictions
and we want to do this in tens of
milliseconds under heavy load and this
whole process now complicated by the
introductions of deep neural networks or
these very large random forests that
really substantially increased the cost
of computation and in some case even
storage and so it requires developments
in both algorithms and systems today I'm
going to focus on systems but we have a
lot of really exciting research around
new kinds of algorithms for predictions
that leverage Cascades or uncertainty to
reduce the costs of evaluating these new
kinds of models so what are the
technologies for prediction serving so
here's a few of the open source ones I
found there are some commercial
offerings as well in fact all the major
cloud providers now have some kind of
offering for prediction serving but I
want to talk about some patterns in
these open source offerings so Clippers
the system we've been building in the UC
Berkeley rise lab some of these other
systems are actually very impressive
although in many cases focused on
particular kinds of models or particular
modeling tasks there's actually not that
it's not a bad thing in many cases those
are all the models you need but with
clip and we're trying to design a more
general framework that can support and
compose a wide range of models and so
now I get to the key part of this talk
with just a few minutes remaining and so
here's what I want to allude to in the
remainder of this talk I want to discuss
some of the challenges of prediction
serving I want to talk a bit about the
Clipper architecture and some of the
insights we learned in the design of
clipper and then I want to talk a little
bit about the open source
effort clipper is a big open source
project with the large number of
graduate students and in fact actually
now undergrads developing the project in
collaboration with some industrial
groups
alright so prediction serving challenges
two big challenges one is the emergence
of these really interesting and complex
and computationally expensive models
that require some specialized hardware
accelerators in many settings and two
and maybe more important is the trend
towards the composition of different
models and frameworks for individual
prediction tasks is no longer the case
the a company has just one model and one
system and one prediction task we often
have many tasks many models and many
systems so we need to address both these
problems the first the need to support
big models so not all models are big in
fact many prediction tasks have fairly
simple models but as we build these more
exciting personalized models neural
networks they increase the cost of
computation in many cases they can take
tens of gigaflops to make a single
prediction to be expensive they're being
deployed along the critical path they
can't fail and they have to do this
under heavy load and to support that
we've been using things like GPUs
advanced in hardware acceleration
parallel computation allocating multiple
cores to a single model so it is
actually a new computational challenge
it's not just a data challenge I mean
actually to point to how big of a
challenge this was you actually can look
at Google Translate neat story so if you
look at the Google Translate in order to
serve these translations of words we
have to do about 140 billion words a day
and if you use the calculations they
provide in their paper that amounts to
roughly 82,000 GPUs running 24/7
assuming a uniform load we don't
actually have uniform loads you're gonna
need to provision more than that that's
a lot of GPUs and so Google is doing the
back the envelope calculations and
starting to think about other things
like voice technology which likewise are
going to demand these new expensive
models and they decided they needed to
develop a new processor so the TPU was
actually designed not for that whole
model development process but address
the challenges of serving so once you
mature is level where you are really
trying to deploy lots of models this
actually becomes the bigger computation
the more expensive computational
challenge
so what we see when we look at a lot of
these big organizations that have a
service like Google ads or voice
translation in many cases they're
building specialized models specialized
systems to support those models for an
entire very specialized service and that
is a good solution when you have a
billion dollar service you need to run
it makes sense to put a lot of resources
into a single model framework but there
are problems and we try to think about
that in a broader context all right so
it is expensive to build and probably
more importantly to maintain each of
these specialized systems for each of
these services it requires expertise
across machine learning and systems so
it's expensive in the human capital
needed to support that it also leads to
tightly coupled models and applications
it makes it hard to innovate on the
application or model independently
because they are so closely coupled and
in many cases only supports a single
machine learning framework and the
downside to that as we saw is it there's
a constant competition between
frameworks what's the best framework
today yeah exactly there are many best
frameworks today there's pie tours
there's tensorflow of their scikit-learn
my graduate students are constantly
switching all their code between PI
torch and penser flow with every you
know update in each of these software
systems right so the frameworks are
changing we can't just support one and
we also as I said not supporting one but
many different prediction applications
so we have a picture looks a lot more
like this many applications and many
different frameworks supporting each of
those applications
all right that's intentionally supposed
to look like a mess because it is a mess
so how do we deal with this mess so if
you're a data engineer and many of you
are you might actually adopt a fairly
simple solution to supporting many these
different applications and that solution
is to pre materialize predictions into a
data management system and then use that
as your serving environment so what does
that look like we return to our picture
of training and inference and actually
we go back to training and during the
process of training or in fact right
after the process of training we use a
big batch processing framework to take
all the possible queries we might see
and materialize to pre predict all the
predictions we might need and then store
them into some serving or scoring
environment first store them into a
database this process is called scoring
one of the advantages
approach is that we're actually able to
live in the batch data engineering space
we can use the tools that we've
developed over time the tools that we
understand well then once we've
constructed this database we can then go
to a serving environment again we're
using the tools that we understand well
we're taking our data management system
and we're having application asking to
look up particular values and those
values return delivering that service
rights this does simplify things and it
lets us have that low latency that we
need for prediction serving but I'm also
gonna argue that this has some big
problems as well so one is it we require
a full set of queries ahead of time that
works when you're just trying to score a
set of products for a small number of
users but if you're trying to process
voice or natural language or comments
this becomes much harder so you need a
small and valid input it can require
substantial computation and storage
space imagine trying to materialize all
the predictions for all the content and
all the users at maybe different points
of the day right so this can be very
expensive to pre-compute
and it becomes more costly to update
we'd like to imagine we can update our
models or adjust them over time if every
single time we have to update a model we
then have to pre-compute all the
possible diction's it might make it
becomes a very computationally instorage
intensive task so now I finally get to
the big point that I wanted to make
about these systems now very briefly
about how we solve these problems and
then I will take some time for some
questions so our approach is to actually
build a middle layer which if you're a
networking person that's exactly what
you see in this picture is that we need
some form of abstraction that can sit
between these machine learning
frameworks use them in their native
capacity provide a common abstraction
and then apply these system
optimizations needed for real-time
serving above the batch training and
prediction frameworks all right so to
find a middle ground between these
specialized systems and the pre
materialization strategy that is
precisely what the clipper project does
it sits as a middle layer application
between these different frameworks and
then uses those native frameworks inside
of docker containers that are then
isolated so you can have separate
environments for each of your models and
still compose them and optimize them in
one common system
so design of clipper the core system
itself is about 10,000 lines probably a
bit more now 10,000 lines of C++ and
Python so we designed it using kind of
low-level tools to focus on latency and
in fact predictable latency I it's open
it's an open source project under the
apache license
it was designed for production level
query traffic so we do research but in
this particular system we wanted a real
system that we could study at scale so
we wanted to deliver low latency and
predictable latency predictions so we to
manage both the the tail effects and the
mean behavior and as I said this is a
research project but it is also a real
software artefact that we are continuing
to develop much in the same spirit as
Apache spark in the rise level so
architectural II what does that mean so
the the implementation of clipper is the
following so we have applications that
interact with clipper inside of a docker
container and all of the models
themselves also live inside of docker
containers so we provide some isolation
management is something we also think
about as again a production level system
should so the state of clippers managed
in a Redis database currently that we're
looking at other ways in managing the
state and then we have separate tools to
actually interact with the clipper
system through this database and then
because again we want to build a real
system we built in support for
Prometheus monitoring of logs and
metrics of each of the models and it
makes pretty plots my students have
shown me all right so the nice way of
actually deploying it we went to some
company and said look put this in
production like well there's one more
thing we went this in kubernetes so we
then work to integrate with the
kubernetes environment so it can be
managed through kubernetes and so it can
live alongside other applications in a
serving environment so this is research
but this is a production level system
and that is the goal of this project
alright so I will talk briefly about how
you can get started so we have tutorials
for clipper I've said clipper AI we have
docker images on docker hub for the
system and we're continuously developing
them
we have clipper admin tools that let you
get started by just using pip so you can
pip install the clipper admin package
and it will launch
for you and the goal is to be able to
get up and running without compiling but
this is a real open source project and
we have open contributors and we
encourage you to check it out download
it and compile and contribute back so I
want to then in the remaining let's say
four minutes mention a few of the key
innovations in clipper things that are
part of the research that if you were
building your own prediction serving
system you might also want to
incorporate so one of the first and it
may be simple but really big insights
was to containerize everything rather
than try to build a monolithic system
and we did rather than try to build a
model system which has all the models
within that serving environment the idea
was to break into lots of little pieces
that we can and manage in isolation we
then as a consequence of that are now
able to lift a lot of the system
optimizations above these frameworks so
we can introduce things like caching and
batch optimization that are critical to
efficient inference in a GPU or a highly
parallel CPU and then we can do things
like cross framework learning so we can
actually learn above the prediction so
it's essentially injecting a model above
you the model you've already trained and
allowing that model to adapt quickly to
feedback so we can start to learn and
even personalize models that themselves
are not able to learn or personalize so
the architecture of clippers I said
Deakin decouples a system each of the
model containers is a separate docker
container it's isolated from the rest it
allows us to then use the tools the
original code and systems required for
training those models in serving as we
talk to a bunch of companies they say
well we're looking at these at that time
PMML technologies it's just not a good
way to capture the entire pipeline that
you have for rendering a prediction in a
way that works across systems so there's
this lost in translation as the models
developed and then re implemented in the
serving context we got rid of that by
essentially using exactly the same tools
as in development and serving but that
means we have to address some of the
mismatch by introducing batching and
caching techniques above that to get the
performance we need the reliable low
latency SL O's needed for prediction
serving we made it fairly simple to
introduce new kinds of models and
frameworks and we added RPC support for
C++ Java PI
and then recently our so we can serve
models in all of these different
languages with their corresponding low
latency low and reliable latency
guarantees I mean as I said because it's
in a container now you can package with
your model and we've built some default
containers but you can build your own
all the dependencies you need to support
that prediction and that means you have
different versions of SPARC different
versions of scikit-learn in terms of
flow all working together to render a
single prediction as I said earlier we
get resource isolation we also get
scaling so we notice that as a
particular model becomes more popular
you can actually automatically add more
instances that model and this the front
end application doesn't know that
anything's changed
it just gets faster so we can
automatically scale individual
components again even in a single
prediction right so a single prediction
might actually call all of these models
at once all right and so as I said there
are few key innovations interior to the
system so we built this common
abstraction layer which allows us to
then support a wide range of models with
a simple API and that's leveraging the
fact that most predictions are really
simple functions that take some basic
input and produce some some output and
then on top of that we did things like
automatic learning across these
different models so Amala composition
layer I'm gonna skip some of the
batching optimizations some really cool
work and how you automatically tune the
execution to get efficient predictions
on a GPU we'll post the slides and you
can take a look at that it's good
research briefly mentioned some of the
cool things that happens in model
selection and compositions so I can take
multiple models into a single prediction
so we might do that is they can have
different versions of a single model
combined with other kinds of models and
I can combine all of those to make a
single prediction and I can use the
uncertainty across these versions and
across these models to start to measure
the uncertainty in my system this is not
an ideal measure of uncertainty but it's
maybe a surrogate that we could use to
make better predictions we started to
study some of the consequence of that
alright so if the each of the models
predicts cat then we might be more
certain if certain models say oh that's
also DJ who might be a little bit unsure
and so we can actually play with this so
if we take these ensembles and we say we
introduced a new class which is I don't
know or idk
so the model can now predict
if we do that we find that we can use
this notion uncertainty and for a tiny
fraction so right here this little bar
here a little bit
so small fractions workload we say we're
unsure and if we had made the prediction
we'd be terribly wrong right but the
things that we're now sure about that
we're willing to make the prediction
they're actually accuracy just got
better so we can improve upon the stay
the art by doing almost nothing we can
do it above the models themselves all
right so it's a way that the serving
environment can actually improve
accuracy you know what I will skip a few
key exciting points so we focus on easy
model development we now have support
for a pretty wide range of common
machine learning frameworks as I said
earlier we've introduced a lot with
metrics and monitoring the project's
under active development 22 contributors
including eight industrial groups so
we're working in with production
deployments and si P Scotiabank Pacific
AI and arm so actively trying to explore
the use of this technology in the real
world so I'll conclude by saying I made
a case for model and data engineering
and I think that some of the opportunity
and challenges outlined here will
transform the way we build machine
learning pipelines in the future and
it's an exciting area to be doing
research and to be building systems I
talked a bit about the machine learning
lifecycle actually a lot about it and I
talked about some of the opportunities
and weaknesses in each of these steps
and then we talked quite a bit about the
Clipper prediction serving system and
some of the ways in which we've started
to think about how to do prediction
serving differently so with that I'd
like to thank you and I'd be happy to
take a few questions
you know what microphones so if you do
ask questions well Michael so it's a
really cool prediction work it's very
exciting I think that's really needed I
think that got me even more excited was
your talk about kinetic canonical data
pipelines to get to the prediction steps
so can you talk a little about that tell
us yes where is the github for data
pipelines and is that something guys are
working on or like so everything in
Clippers amazing I'm just that first
that big pipeline thing is the reason I
brought in the talk not just focus on
clipper
so the pipeline part is particularly
exciting let me actually talk about my
errors and naming again the floor
project used to be called the Jarvis
project Jarvis is a very popular names
we decided maybe shouldn't call it that
one of the reasons we did call it Jarvis
is that we were thinking what would the
Jenkins of machine learning look like
what would a continuous integration
framework do and so when we started
Jarvis now called floor one of the
things that we wanted to do is be able
to capture the pipeline and so we
actually we're looking at Jarvis in
contrast to something like air flow so
we wanted to be able to capture all the
stages the code and the data so we look
at something like air flow it's
convenient that it's agnostic to the
underlying modeling components if I put
that in contrast to ml lib Keystone ml
cycler and pipelines each of these
builds a pipeline a way of describing
each of your data transformations with
your models but all tied to a particular
framework it take something like air
flow it doesn't care it's just running
code the problem is something like air
flows it doesn't really track the data
that's sort of outside of the scope of
the system but when you're developing
models you do want to know about the
versions of the data that were used
you'd like to track that as well so we
started with Jarvis thinking about how
to capture that pipeline the current
version of floor again derives from
Jarvis actually has some annotation
tools that you can now instrument in
Python only currently each step of your
pipeline and you can a call out to an
external library and say this is going
through you can tell Jarvis you're going
to run some external code and it should
track the final file that's produced I
don't care how that's going to happen so
I don't actually have in
to the what the codes doing but I do
know which code was run and the file
that was produced and I conversion those
two things that's an early step I think
there are a big opportunity to build a
pipeline framework that can span
different machine learning tools data
transformation tools that can track code
data and people and that's where we want
to take the floor project but that's
that's the big opportunity so what about
a pipeline for production meaning you
get this amazing model it's complex
instead of taking ten parameters and it
takes a million how do you scale that so
that's that's the other thing getting
from development pipeline to a
production pipeline that I'm interested
in yeah I don't have a good answer so
there are a lot of opportunities once
you go from development to training to
make that more efficient to decide when
to retrain a model as new data arrives
to validate a model to make sure you're
not overfitting in that process and then
to take that knowledge and use it during
prediction serving which also needs to
know about the transformations were used
to transform the new inputs at query
time at scale yeah
actually I'll add one more thing so one
of the new things we're doing in clipper
right now and my students are working on
it hopefully is a system called infer
line which actually allows you to
automatically provision a cluster so one
of the big challenges in model serving
is knowing how many GPUs how many CPUs
and how to split your models over those
GPUs and CPUs to get the throughput you
need with the latency requirements that
you need for the appropriate batch size
of each of those systems to make them
efficient and to do all of that for
these complex compositions and so we've
been studying a way of using arrival
processes so models of how data how
queries are arriving to optimally tune
these systems to minimize costs it's
actually pretty challenging work but it
is possible to profile models and then
find a good cluster allocation on an
optimal cluster allocation it brings
down costs
you